ja ein schwieriges dilemma über das ich
jetzt sprechen kann mit dem cdu
parteivorsitzenden live zugeschaltet aus
arnsberg schönen guten abend friedrich
merz guten morgen herr merz wir haben es
gerade im beitrag gehört angela merkel
hat fest darauf vertraut dass die
abhängigkeit von russischen rohstoffen
nicht zum problem werden würde für
deutschland wie blauäugig ist das
gewesen
naja mehr angela merkel war ja in dieser
einschätzung nicht allein es waren ja
große teile der deutschen wirtschaft es
war ein großer teile auch anderer
parteien die spd hatte eine sehr enge
persönliche nähe zu putin und seinem
system und heute stehen wir in der tat
sie haben sie in dem beitrag wie ich
finde richtig beschrieben vor dem
scherbenhaufen dieser energiepolitik das
nützt nun alles nichts darüber zu
lamentieren wir müssen versuchen nach
vorne zu schauen und sollten versuchen
die selben fehler die in der
vergangenheit gemacht worden sind nicht
zu wiederholen sie selber haben auch
schon gesagt die usa haben es leichter
jetzt sich von russischem öl zu trennen
eben weil die abhängigkeit nicht da ist
aber noch einmal ihre partei bzw cdu csu
die union hat in den 16 jahren ihrer
regierungsverantwortung diese
abhängigkeit mit vorangetrieben da
trifft sie doch jetzt noch eine
mitverantwortung
frau b natürlich natürlich und das
bestreitet ja niemand von uns aber in
den letzten 19 der letzten 23 jahre
waren sozialdemokraten in der regierung
und wir haben dort einen ehemaligen
bundeskanzler der mittlerweile zum gas
lobbyisten der russen geworden ist also
bitte wenn wir über verantwortung reden
dann nicht allein über die der union wir
bekennen uns dazu und jetzt müssen wir
gemeinsam schauen dass wir aus diesem
wirklich großen dilemma wieder
herauskommen an dramatik der ukrainische
botschafter hier in deutschland hat eine
sehr klare vorstellung wie man dieses
dilemma lösen sollte denn nimmt mit
einem klaren bekenntnis zu einem
komplett embargo zur verweigerung
deutschlands dieses energie embargos
sagt er das sei wie ein messer in den
rücken der ukraine auch sie persönlich
haben sich schon gegen einen komplett
embargo ausgesprochen warum eigentlich
naja
die folgen wären ja nun wirklich
unabsehbar wir hätten wahrscheinlich
sofort stillstand in großen teilen der
deutschen industrie wir hätten
erhebliche folgen auf dem arbeitsmarkt
wir würden soziale verwerfungen in
diesem lande sehen die beträchtlich sind
und insofern teile ich die einschätzung
des bundeswirtschaftsministers robert
habeck und wir sind in einem furchtbaren
dilemma wir wünschen uns ja nichts mehr
als ein schnelles ende dieses krieges
wir alle wollen alles tun um ihn so
schnell wie möglich hier zu beenden
aber wir dürfen nun auch nicht ja uns
selber noch zusätzlich so massiv
schädigen indem wir zu einem solchen
embargo kommen
wenn ich sie da unterbrechen darf sagt
für ein paar monate sei das machbar wie
erklären sie herrn melnik dass sie
diesen preis nicht zahlen wollen
wir haben im fraktionsvorstand der
unionsfraktion in der letzten woche über
dieses thema mehrere stunden beraten und
ich werde der fraktion auch in dieser
woche noch einmal den vorschlag machen
wenigstens den ausstieg aus nord stream
1 zu erwägen das würde nach unserer
einschätzung nicht zu solchen
versorgungsengpässen führen dass es
gleich stillstand in der wirtschaft gibt
und keine heizung mehr in den wohnungen
aber das wäre eine erhebliche
einschränkung und noch einmal wir sind
hier alle in einem wirklich schweren
dilemma gleich wie wir uns entscheiden
ja wir lassen hier schuld auf uns aber
so ist das manchmal in einer politischen
situation wie der die wir jetzt alle
vorfinden gehen sie mal bitte davon aus
dass wir hier alle wirklich unser
gewissen täglich prüfen zu welchen
entscheidungen wir kommen könnten und
aus der opposition heraus wollen wir die
bundesregierung auch unterstützen wir
wollen und wir suchen auch einen
gemeinsamen weg in deutschland noch
einmal um das ziel zu erreichen und das
ziel heißt möglichst schnelle beendigung
dieses schrecklichen krieges grund
welchen preis das kosten wird das werden
wir am ende sehen herzlichen dank für
das gespräch ich bedanke mich bei ihnen